the PM has been out defending her
agreement this morning the big question
of course is is that enough for you do
you think you'd back it in Commons votes
well the first big question is whether
it will be agreed with the EU because if
there isn't a deal there's nothing to
vote on but the the principles that are
in the proposals to the EU which to have
a customs arrangement and a deal on
immigration if they're met they are the
two key principles behind what's needed
for a clean clear brexit in other words
we leave but we don't sacrifice our
manufacturing industry in exchange for
World Trade Organization rules which
would not be good for the country and
would shift control to countries like
Japan and China and we'd be taking their
rules which isn't in our interests do
you think that there is much difference
between the Labour Party's official
position on brexit what it wants to see
and what Teresa May is proposing in this
checkers agreement well there's
differences of emphasis and but when it
comes with substantive issues a customs
arrangement that means frictionless
trade that means no tariffs that means
for the the viewers that food prices
don't go up
for example dairy products 43 percent
increase under the world trade rules car
prices up 10% on every car under world
trade rules which will be the decimation
of the car industry and the aerospace
industry
I think this agreement on that I think
there's agreement on the principles of
immigration listening to what Jeremy
Corbyn saying and what the Prime
Minister's saying that we need a deal on
immigration that allows people with
skills in but puts restrictions on cheap
unskilled labour both the saying that
and there's agreement that we have to
leave that we're not having a second
referendum and so I think actually
there's a lot more in common
that perhaps both of them would care to
admit so why do you think it is that
labor currently saying that they
wouldn't be prepared to back the steel
we spoke to Tom Watson Labor's deputy
leader a bit earlier on the show and he
was making it quite clear that at the
minute he doesn't think labor would
support the proposals but if what you're
saying is true that there's not that
much difference between them apart from
a difference in emphasis why are they
doing that well when it comes to the
wire
if trees are mainly go shi'ites this
dealing gets agreement then the choice
influence of parliament will be either a
No Deal
in other words World Trade Organization
rules which is 10% on the price of cars
huge increases in food prices decimation
of the aerospace and a number of other
manufacturing industries that's one
option or the second option will be the
deal that she's agreed with the European
Union I'd be surprised if there aren't
lots of Labour MPs if there is the
choice including something rational on
immigration where we have control over
our borders if that's what's on offer
then I can see quite a lot of Labour MPs
will when it comes to it in that final
vote vote for it rather than try and
scoop a brexit so you think that it
could be Labour MPs opposition MPs who
effectively get to reason a over the
line when it comes to this brexit deal
well the idea that it's not that
palatable to be going through any voting
lobby with treasom a and her gang but
neither is it to be going through any
vote in lobby with Jacob Riis Morgan
Steve Baker who are interested in the
speculative financial world but in doing
over our manufacturing that's not in the
interests of my constituency in the
north of England it's not an interest of
working-class people it's not an
interest of the country so I don't want
to be in a situation where I'm going in
and I won't be going in some vote in
Lobby
Jacob Riis MOG and those who want a
second referendum in some unholy
alliance I'll not be voting in the same
lobby as them and I've never quite a lot
of Labour MPs who will balk at the idea
that they're going to go in the same
Lobby as those who want to skip a break
seat and those such as Jacob Riis MOG
who've got this fanciful idea that we
can survive in this country without a
car industry without an aerospace
industry without manufacturing and put
up food prices hugely for working people
that's not a good deal so when it comes
to it that is quite a possibility and
I'm interested in what you're saying
there about sharing a voting Lobby with
people who want a second referendum
people who in your words want to try and
scupper brexit because at the minute the
Labour leadership isn't ruling out what
they call a people's vote is that
something that concerns you well
everything I've heard from Jeremy Corbyn
he's ruling that out I think he'll stick
to that I certainly hope you he will and
lose the working class if he doesn't but
there are some and they're very open
about it they want to scupper breaks it
they've been quite clear about it well
I'll not be voting when it comes to any
final deal if it's on offer in the same
lobby as those who want to skip a brexit
and if they're in the lobby with Jacob
Riis MOG then I think the public will be
asking some very big questions I think
people are bit baffled and bemused at
what's going on they want us to get out
of the European Union as they vote for
it on the best terms possible and I
don't think anyone out there wants to
see 10% on the price of cars and huge
increases on the price of food that
would not be popular it's not what
people vote for it's not what I voted
for and I Rhys Morgan his little gang
needs to be honest that one they say No
Deal what they mean is we abide by the
rules and regulations of the World Trade
Organization and that's disastrous for
aerospace disastrous for the car
industry car prices up 10% and food
prices up between some foods over 40% so
let them be honest about that